was geht hier ab was habe ich getan was
habe ich nur getan freunde was ist das
für ein hallo mein name ist luca und ich
werde dann von dieser scheiße da
geblendet alter herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge der minecraft
commands in minecraft das war wieder
eine tolle zusatzinformationen luca ich
habe heute nur das geht echt überhaupt
nicht klar mit dem ich mal kurz
irgendwas zum abdecken kann doch nicht
sein aber jetzt muss ich da ich bin
übrigens wieder nur in boxershorts
unterwegs sie müssen wissen meine videos
irgendwie man nur in unterwäsche schön
alles hingekriegt perfekt werde ich noch
geblendet haha scheiss weg sonne alter
wer brauchte ich schon ich habe heute
nur einen punkt am start aber hört mir
zu einfach zu mann lukas wir fangen
jetzt endlich an also dieser command ist
von mct sts und zwar gehen wir erstmal
einen / gfp command unterstrich block um
das essentielle notwendige für diese
serie zu bekommen und zwar einen command
block und dazu wird auch ein level
setzen das ganze hinführt den fügen den
command 1 alles klar drücken auf den
lämmer und es wird etwas generiert und
zwar wie sie heute nur einkommen an
diesen command entdecken heute zusammen
ich habe ihn schon mit testet er
funktioniert ich habe schon das erste
item getestet allerdings hat man
irgendwie so 12 items oder sohn wir
werden uns hier heute einfach mal
zusammen anschauen also sondern etwas
andere folge der command eigentlich
hatte ich einfach keine zeit mit 3,1 zu
suchen weil ich heute schon klausur
geschrieben habe und alles mögliche da
war mein gott also es ist dann hier
aufgebaut was geht er mit dem chat schon
wieder ab es gibt irgendein command dass
man das ausmachen kann aber keine ahnung
also man erstmal ob es hier einfach mal
im 18
dann sehen wir das nicht so krass also
wir haben hier wandel am etios getty aus
command bei mcts get meteor rain oder
hier geld mit ihr euch weiß gar nicht
ich kann hier einmal drauf drücken da
bekomme ich die verschiedenen meteors
das heißt sammeln normal ist dann
heilige scheiße bevor ich jetzt hier
vergessen muss sich mal ganz kurz eben
eine halbe minute über was reden und
zwar dieses tube clash moting und ich
sehe halt immer dass alle youtuber die
dabei sind zehn trilliarden fach diesen
dummen votings pannen wenig zuschauer
von irgendeinem youtuber wäre dann hätte
ich keinen bock darauf dass ich immer
zugemüllt werde mit den links überall
deswegen freunde jetzt hier ganz
speziell an wirklich die leute die jetzt
gerade da sondern die echten zuschauer
wenn ihr denkt ich bock drauf habt dass
ich bei dieser serie mit dabei bin dann
könnt ihr mal und in die beschreibung
schauen und zwar findet ihr dort ganz
oben einen sonnen link wo steht tube
clash contra verboten wenn ihr darauf
klickt und pro klick krieg ich halt eine
stimme das heißt sie können das auch
aktualisieren oder keine ahnung was da
durch gibt er mir das stimme wenn ihr
wollt dass ich wirklich dabei bin ich
habe mich gegenüber dem ganzen projekt
am anfang erst negativ geäußert nicht
weil ich das projekt nicht mag sondern
weil ich einfach diese fertigen
kriterien dumm finde man muss einfach
nur das video anklicken und es macht
einfach überhaupt keinen sinn das heißt
die mit der größten fan base gewinnen da
das fand ich halt ein bisschen unfair
deswegen wenn ihr nicht wollt dass ich
da rein komme und denkt mit anderen
leuten witziger ich kenne auch witziger
wende henndorf blatt dabei wäre oder
irgendwie ich fans auch witzig wenn da
die dabei wäre weil ich einfach witzig
fand was das team daraus macht einfach
finde story schreibt und ich weiß nicht
auf 70 wären wir nicht dabei bin wenn
ich bin totaler und witziger typ bin
aber wenn ihr wirklich dafür sei die
oder kong crafter muss da rein dann
könnt ihr auf den link klickt ich werde
den link hier einmal post und vielleicht
noch mal kurz vorm ende einmal aber euch
nicht die ganze damit zumüllen das war
es damit ich würde ich das video damit
jetzt was wir machen weiter mit den
alten es dann haben wir hier sammeln
plain also wenn ich das hin setzte kommt
etwas anders damit ist das ist ein
flaches einfach oder sammeln ocelot das
hört sich an als ob er gleich gegen eine
wasserbombe oder irgendwie drauf rein
kommt und zwar kommt eine genau eine
wasserbombe und ganz viele wächter das
ist super okay das hier ist sammeln
das kommt wahrscheinlich ja genau das
eis und schnee männer alles klar dann
haben wir noch zusammen hält da kommt
wenn ich jetzt gruppen vermuten müsste
irgendwie nett adrett oder du hast
wahrscheinlich ja genau netter raider
ziegel lover sogar unter gott
steht und jetzt greifen die elcom schnee
mehr fällt auch nur auf der suche nach
stress kommt geht euch einfach mal bitte
vergraben das doch mal die bitte links
da in ruhe die man soll die nicht
aggressiv machen behindert die schießt
die ganze zeit gegen das hallo thema
bitte sterben einfach danke zusammen
haben wir hier das hört sich definitiv
so an als ob er jetzt alles klar
es kommt einfach alles irgendwie
zusammen
deshalb haben wir auch noch da kommen
wahrscheinlich sand blöcke und viele
sandhügel dingsbums und playa games ist
gold und dann haben wir hier noch
sammeln creeper lincoln wenn man hier
hinsetzen da kommt dann prima was ein
zufall dass bei creeper creeper kommen
und dann haben wir hier noch sammeln and
was da jetzt passiert kann ich mir
ehrlich gesagt nicht so lange ja okay
diese entsteinen und halt wieder ganz
normaler materie also jeder meteor macht
ein bisschen schaden auf diese kritik
allerdings ja mir schaden gemacht und s
bahn halt immer noch was dazu also ganz
normaler mädchen natürlich einfach nur
ganz normal so ein loch aber der rest
sport halt immer noch ein paar
zusätzliche sachen ich die leute mal
kurz alles was ich hier drin ab dass
bereits ganz oben wo ich gedrückt da
jetzt wirklich mal hier drauf und zwar
kriegen wir jetzt so ein paar andere
items bzw
also ich weiß nicht ob die jetzt
irgendwas anderes machen wenn ich das
jetzt im wechsel
das ist auf jeden fall schon mal mehr
creeper ich setze jetzt einfach mal ein
paar andere hier nebeneinander ist aber
normal aus
sie und noch was habe ich deswegen jetzt
kommt ist aber ob ich am lecken gerade
hier okay wir auf jeden fall definitiv
sehr sehr viele wächter gerade am start
ansporn ich jetzt mal eben schnell hell
on earth und das wandern
vielmehr die gastgeber wieder so alles
klar ist okay ist okay alles vdm
da habe ich gerade aber echt ein
bisschen sehr viel kaputt gemacht mit
der ganzen seite und dann haben wir hier
noch sammelt xp da kommt wahrscheinlich
erfahrungspunkte oder wie mir nicht auch
jungs einfach erfahrung geil
das ist mit der geilste meteor von allen
bisher wieder heiß summons moll feiere
ich setzte damals einfach hier auf die
bäume um zu schauen ob da jetzt okay das
kleine feuer entwickelt sich
wahrscheinlich gerade zu einem etwas
größeren feuern und dann haben wir neben
dem sammeln small feier noch einsammeln
normales feiere ich setze jetzt mal
hierhin und hierhin und ihr seht schon
da kommt jetzt echt ein bisschen
größeres feuer das aber tatsächlich
eigentlich gar nichts anzünde das war's
jetzt von diesen halte ich mir gerade
geholt habt wie kann ich mal eben wieder
löschen und jetzt schauen wir noch mal
eben was passiert wenn ich da hinten
drauf drücken da bekomme ich noch mal
drei items und zwar einmal zusammen xp
was damit jetzt passieren soll ist
wahrscheinlich wieder xp aber nur einer
oder wie oder was steht da smart meter
sind
das ist sind kleine das sind die regen
arten und das ist da
ludwig bitz laden verstünden hier kommt
man wahrscheinlich einfach ein kleines
feuer genau und wenn hier kommt ein
kleiner feuerball
genauso ist das ganze aufgebaut ja das
war dann quasi schon der komplette
inhalt dieses command okay was heißt
schon das ist einfach so so viel was
hier mit hinzugefügt wurde aber wir sind
natürlich kein langweiliger kanal
sondern was ihr natürlich auch alle
sehen wollte haye luca was passiert
eigentlich wenn du hier mal alles
versucht so gleichzeitig zu steuern
dann sitzen wir hier noch ein paar hier
sitzt man noch mal hier sind normal hier
wird normal hier der vdm alter das ist
gerade der ultra lag am bienenfreunde
was geht hier ab was habe ich getan was
habe ich nur getan freunde was ist das
für ein scheiß koman ich beende an
dieser stelle das video wenn es euch
gefallen da würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen ich habe gerade zwei
fcl kommt sehen uns im nächsten video
wieder ihr findet den schülern stehen
genaue beschreibungen und gealtert dem
freundes und was habe ich denn da getan